well as you know there are often not
that many things that Democrats are
doing correctly for themselves and
sometimes Democrats are sort of relying
on or hoping that Republicans will mess
themselves up it's not a great strategy
but to the extent that it's useful you
do love to see it and the latest is that
Marjorie Taylor green the repugnant and
radical republican congresswoman from
Georgia is furious that Tulsi gabbard
hammered Republican Congressman elect
liar George Santos on Fox News two
nights ago so let me remind you what
happened George Santos is a huge liar
lied about his job history lied about
his educational history lied about being
Jewish maybe lied about the
circumstances of his mother's death lie
lie lie lie lie uh he appeared with
Tulsi gabbard who used to be a Democrat
now she's not next thing you know Tulsi
gabbard's campaigning for Kerry Lake and
Herschel Walker and filling in for
Tucker Carlson but to her credit Tulsi
did a good job to some degree of holding
George Santos accountable Marjorie
Taylor green did not like it unleashing
a fascinating series of tweets insofar
as it tells us a lot about how these
people think about politics let's look
at the Tweet thread this is again
Marjorie Taylor green not happy with
Tulsi quote Tulsi gabbard who says she
is a former Democrat gave representative
elect George Santos zero Grace while
George is admitting and apologizing for
lying about his resume just like her
former colleagues are giving George zero
Grace and even demanding he resigned
remember he didn't admit and apologize
he minimized called them embellishments
said the explanation would go over the
voters heads because they couldn't
possibly understand it and on and on and
on to say it was an apology is a little
bit much
okay Marjorie continuing quote Tulsi
says that George's actions on the house
floor are what is most important but
George has not even had the chance to
take action for his district on the
house floor because he isn't even sworn
in yet Tulsi also says how can his
district believe anything he says when
he is standing on the house floor
fighting for them that's a good question
I too believe actions and words are
extremely important but I don't think a
former Democrat Whose actions on the
house floor as recent as 2020 that gave
her an a from Planned Parenthood an F
from the NRA and introduced the climate
agenda signature piece of legislation
called The Off act designed to end all
fossil fuels the same as aoc's green New
Deal should lecture a newly elected
Republican member of Congress on how he
should vote to represent his Republican
district oh boy
um Marjorie continuing this tirade quote
I do appreciate that Tulsi says words
that sound conservative now even though
she can't take action to back them up I
am glad she like George realized she
made mistakes and was wrong every time
she voted to support killing The Unborn
taking away our gun rights and
legislated to kill America's energy
Independence and the fossil fuel
industry I hoped we'll see a sincere
just like I hope George is sincere I
think we Republicans should give George
Santos a chance and see how he
legislates and votes not treat him the
same as the left is listen there is not
even the smallest doubt
that were George Santos a Democrat
Marjorie Taylor green and all of these
people would be treating him completely
differently and to some degree although
I'm not a fan of Tulsi gabbards
she seems to be treating him the way he
deserves to be treated based on his
actions not because of his party
designation similarly
I hope you all know
that my position on George Santos would
be exactly the same if he were a
Democrat and as you all know this idea
that there's a double standard among
everybody when it comes to these wrong
these types of wrongdoing is very much
untrue I don't know anyone on the left
who was defending Anthony Weiner when he
was involved in sexting minors and
whatever all the different things that
he did when that Democratic Congressman
I believe it was was caught with 10
grand in his freezer I didn't defend him
I don't know anybody that did it is not
all the same and while Marjorie Taylor
green wants to claim
that it is the left with the double
standard it is really her ilk the Maga
people
Etc the only
really good take here from Marjorie
Taylor green like I would if you said to
me David sir what would be an
intellectually honest reaction from
Marjorie Taylor green that defends
George Santos it would be if Marjorie
Taylor green came forward and said
listen
let's not be hard on George Santos
because at the end of the day our entire
party really is as dishonest as he is
like when we say cutting taxes for the
rich is good for the economy that's just
as dishonest and more damaging than when
he said he graduated from college that
would be a surprisingly refreshing
accurate uh take from Marjorie Taylor
green not the argument she's making
Marjorie Taylor green as is almost
always the case coming up with the worst
take on every issue a constant liar a
consistent liar and she lacks total
morals values and ethics and that's part
of why she has no problem with the lies
told by George Santos I don't hate the
infighting you all know that I think
it's good for the left the left needs
help any help the left can get I think
we should take assuming we're not doing
anything illegal or immoral and
certainly letting them fight amongst
themselves uh has nothing immoral or
illegal to it